-I am so excited about this.
Tonight,
we are coming to you live!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Live!
Whoa!
And this is very special --
our entire audience
is filled with Democrats
who are running for president.
So, unbelievable.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Fantastic.
Congratulations.
Yeah, just like the debate,
everyone here
gets 10 seconds to talk.
[ Laughter ]
And since it's NBC,
if you go past your time,
you're gonna hear this.
[ Dramatic tone ]
Okay.
That's the way it works.
Now, the debate
was right here at NBC,
and there was a lot
of excitement in the building.
It felt
just like the Super Bowl,
you know, if 20 teams
played the game over two nights
and the winner wasn't decided
for another year.
But besides that...
But it's true -- we're live,
and we just watched the first
Democratic debate down in Miami.
If you missed it,
here's what happened.
There were 10 Democrats
on stage, and to qualify,
all a candidate needed
was to poll at 1% or higher.
[ Laughter ]
That's it?
One per--
I mean, even O.J. is at 2%.
-Oh.
[ Laughter ]
-But once it got under way,
something very interesting
happened.
In his first question
of the night,
Beto O'Rourke decided
to start speaking Spanish.
Watch this.
-And it's gonna take all of us
coming together
to make sure that it does.
[ Speaking Spanish ]
[ Laughter ]
-Cory Booker's face.
Oh, Cory B-- yeah.
Trump was watching like, "Crap.
Did I hit the SAP button?
What is it?
What is it?"
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Then, when they called on
Bill de Blasio, he was like,
"Uh, thank-a you-o.
I'm-a happy to be here-o."
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, Cory Booker
saw Beto speaking Spanish
and decided to join in, too.
Watch him.
-[ Speaking Spanish ]
[ Laughter ]
-He sounds
like Arnold Schwarzenegger
learning Rosetta Stone.
He's like...
[ Speaking Spanish loudly ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Meanwhile, over on Telemundo,
they were speaking English.
-Really?
-It was unbelievable tonight.
-Wow!
-Yeah, Beto and Booker
both spoke Spanish,
but it's not that crazy
because Miami has a large
Spanish-speaking community.
I just hope that the next debate
is in Boston
so I can hear them say,
"We need free college
for anyone who is wicked smart."
[ Laughter ]
Later on, we got our first look
at one of the underdogs,
former Maryland Congressman
John Delaney.
Take a look at this guy.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
He looks like a talking thumb.
Well, as expected,
Elizabeth Warren and Cory Booker
did well tonight,
but I actually thought
Bill de Blasio
did a pretty good job, too.
The New Yorkers are like,
"Where the hell's
this friggin' guy been?
Hey, whoa, hey!"
Meanwhile, later on --
[ Feedback ]
-Welcome back to "Today" --
-Sorry, sorry.
That's a mic.
Can someone turn
Savannah Guthrie's
microphone off?
Thank you. Appreciate it.
So, during the debate,
there were
some technical difficulties.
Take a look at this.
-Should there be a role
for the federal government --
-The mics are on.
-Everybody's mics are on.
Think we had
a little mic issue in the back.
-Control room,
we've got contrary audio.
-We had the --
I think we heard --
Yeah, we have
the audience audio.
-What's happening?
[ Laughter ]
-Then Vladimir Putin was like,
"Is too easy."
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughs ]
Now, get this -- Trump tweeted
and called the debate boring.
But he still watched
even though he also said
it was a "very unexciting
group of people."
As opposed to the rock stars
he usually hangs out with,
like Mike Pence
and Steve Mnuchin.
[ Laughter ]
But I think
I know why Trump's upset.
He's probably
jealous of the Democrats.
You know, if you think about it,
they got to be on TV,
they got
to talk about themselves,
and they got to be in Florida.
It's like, "These are
my three favorite things!
I can't believe it!"
[ Laughter ]
There's a lot going on
in the race,
and there's
so many Democrats running,
it's hard to keep up,
so we thought we'd help you out.
Enjoy.
♪♪
-♪ Bernie Sanders ♪
-♪ Tulsi Gabbard ♪
-♪ Julián Castro ♪
-♪ Beto O'Rourke ♪
-♪ Elizabeth Warren ♪
-♪ John Delaney ♪
-♪ Kirsten Gillibrand
from New York ♪
-♪ Cory Booker ♪
-♪ Andrew Yang ♪
-♪ I'm Bill de Blasio ♪
-♪ Tim Ryan ♪
-♪ Michael Bennet ♪
-♪ I'm Eric Swalwell ♪
-♪ Marianne Williamson ♪
-♪ Joe Biden ♪ [ Laughs ]
-♪ I'm Jay Inslee ♪
-♪ Kamala Harris ♪
-♪ My name is Pete Buttigieg ♪
-♪ I'm Amy Klobuchar ♪
♪ And I approve this message ♪
-Yay!
-♪ I'm John Hickenlooper ♪
♪ Skinny kid
with a funny last name ♪
-♪ Now,
who the hell's gonna beat me? ♪
♪ Their policies
are just insane ♪
-♪ Gun control ♪
-♪ Equality ♪
-♪ Climate change ♪
-♪ Voting rights ♪
-♪ Campaign finance ♪
-♪ Free tuition ♪
-♪ Living wages ♪
-♪ Will not deny
social justice ♪
-♪ Join the fight ♪
♪ Identify ♪
-♪ A woman's right ♪
-♪ It's true ♪
-♪ No excuse ♪
-♪ We can't afford to lose ♪
-♪ Democratic candidates are
here to change the world today ♪
-♪ I'm gonna change my slogan ♪
♪ We'll sell many,
many more hats that way ♪
-♪ Focus on the future ♪
-♪ There is nothing
we can't overcome ♪
-♪ Democratic candidates are
not afraid of Donald Trump ♪
-♪ When people come after me ♪
♪ That's really, really,
really dumb ♪
-♪ Democratic candidates
will never defeat Donald Trump ♪
-♪ Extreme radical Democrats ♪
-Thank you very much.
-There you go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I hope that helps.
[ Applause ]
And did you
see the stage tonight?
All the candidates were standing
in front of a fake White House.
Take a look at this.
Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile,
inside the real White House,
Trump was
looking out the window like,
"Why can't I see them?
Am I in the wrong --
Am I in the Upside Down?"
[ Laughter ]
Earlier today, each candidate
got to spend a few minutes
doing a walk-through
on the stage
just to check out the mics
and all that stuff.
Most of them
wore suits and dresses,
but Ohio Congressman Tim Ryan
did things a little differently.
Watch this.
-All right, 2020 contender
Tim Ryan is on the debate stage
right now
doing his walk-through.
That's gonna be happening
through the course of the day.
-He's like, "Hurry up, dude!
I got to get to the quad
for Frisbee golf!
I mean, what's going on?!"
[ Laughter ]
Guys, it seems like
there's so much going on
in the news right now.
The Democratic debates
are this week,
everybody's talking about
"Toy Story 4,"
Wimbledon is also starting up,
and KFC just announced a new
Cheetos Chicken Sandwich.
There's a lot to go over,
so let's all just jump in,
cover it all at once.
It's time for a News Smash.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
First up,
the Democratic debates.
10 Democrats
went head-to-head tonight,
and 10 more
will do the same thing tomorrow.
There are some
obvious front-runners,
but other candidates
aren't very popular at all.
You know what is popular?
"Toy Story 4."
It's part of one of the most
successful film franchises ever.
These movies
get people so emotional,
by the time
they leave the theater,
they're an absolute mess.
Speaking of absolute messes,
KFC's new Cheetos sandwich.
It's fried chicken
with Cheetos on top,
drenched in
a Cheetos-flavored sauce.
If you're the kind of person who
plans on ordering this thing,
you know what
you probably won't be doing?
Competing at Wimbledon.
It's the biggest, classiest
tennis tournament of the year,
where players are required
to wear all white.
You know who shouldn't
wear all white?
Anyone trying to eat
KFC's Cheetos sandwich.
I mean, all the Cheeto dust,
and this thing
can't be good for you.
The number of calories
probably goes all the way
to infinity and beyond.
[ Laughter ]
The "Toy Story" movies
have introduced us
to so many great characters,
it's hard to keep up.
You know what else
is hard to keep up with?
All these Democrats.
They just keep going
back and forth and back forth.
You know what else
goes back and forth?
Tennis!
And qualifying for Wimbledon
takes years
of blood, sweat, and tears.
Speaking of tears, "Toy Story."
These movies
can cause a lot of heartache,
but if you really want
your heart to hurt,
why not try
KFC's Cheetos sandwich?
In conclusion, good luck,
good luck, good luck, good luck.
[ Cheers and applause ]